do you ask the question you said yes
what do you say about research right so
there's
the the one thing with tom give you a
perfect example with tom i've spent a
lot of time with tom
tom and i have traveled i don't know how
many places we've gone to together
i tell you one thing about tom okay if
you watch his case studies the guys
like yesterday's ducati case study that
just came out today sick we watch it on
the drive to miami right
sick you learn so much about it right
one of tom's biggest strength i learned
from him
okay just watching him not even like
asking him
tom's a master researcher okay
he researches so is greg's share so is
the most successful people i've done
business with
there is this ability to research that
people don't put value behind
so even today with nfts yesterday when i
was calling uh we were on the phone with
jake yesterday on the way to miami
and i'm talking about bitcloud because
i'm getting ready to you know introduce
it to a few different people and
we're talking to crypto attorneys can
they be sued how can you be sued are you
selling securities what could happen
what could not happen you got to do
research to get your questions
yeah so so these these things with cards
these things with nfts we're being hit
up by so many different angles right now
so many different things are being
talked about right now that we don't
know about
so rather than just jumping in and
saying i'm going to go in there and i
mean i don't know what's going on
i'm going to do it why don't you take a
full day and research two of the topics
that interest you the most
exactly that's all i'm talking about you
know that's what you got to be doing you
got to do your own case studies so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye
you